let's talk about the data for a second
because I think that's also kind of
scary for people and since you have
Google as an investor in you're a little
bit associated with that company people
are a little bit scared about data and
you kept talking about the consumers are
in their data and that's really
important to you what data do you own
and what are the data rights especially
to the people who maybe did this at a
discounted price and should people be
absolutely scared that something's going
to happen with their data so I think
over so this the whole concept of like
being terrified of data I think in part
comes because like traditionally in
research or actually in a lot of
companies even like you sign over the
rights and then they never tell you what
happens and part of what we're like in
you know I when I was on Wall Street and
I would hear about this like this idea
of a human subject like you fill out a
long consent form and then you sign away
your rights and you are a human subject
like kind of terrifies me like I want to
know what you're doing with it
I had one really yeah I've had some
scary experience with doctors are like
oh I took a picture of you in this way
and I use it in a presentation and I'm
like what you did what did you do yeah
and and so most people don't know what
they've signed so we're trying to do the
exact opposite where we're trying to say
like we will honor your privacy and
privacy being defined as a definition of
like who do you want to share with it
might be that you want to share with no
one and it might be that you are an
individual with sarcoma
and you want all researchers in the
world to have access to it and so we
want to enable you to control your data
and so it's a really about that control
so you sign up 80% of our customers
consent for research and then once
you're in that research pool you have
the additional opportunity of saying do
you want to take a survey on sexuality
you don't have to some people might be
opposed you can you cannot you want to
take a survey on Parkinson's you want to
take a survey on allergies
so depending on what's of interest to
you you can kind of vote with your feet
about what is it that's of interest and
then we say we're gonna do partnerships
with with pharma companies and academics
but in the aggregate data level right
and so your individual level information
is never going out the door but it's the
aggregate information
and if we ever are gonna do a project
with your individual level data we'll go
back and we'll ask for your explicit
consent and we'll get an email and I'll
check a box you'll get a name I mean
usually it involves more work like hey
can I come and get a punch biopsy from
you yeah so so you're quite aware right
but people have been the consent rates
that we have for individual level data
is extraordinarily high and I think part
of like you see the goodwill enthusiasm
the people who want to go and do walks
and you know participate and change the
world like if all of you had a friend
who's like oh my child has epilepsy will
you help me with this like could you
deposit everyone's gonna do it and so
that's kind of what we're trying to tap
into is like how'd you do that and
really doing it for good we have kind of
this title like the genetics for good
like you can do good things and the most
important thing for me is like you
should be aware of it so when we do
contracts with farm and part in
academics one of the big contention
points we have is we have a requirement
that you have to publish and open access
journals again because like that whole
world's never going to change but like
it's insulting to me that if I have a
consumer population of 8 or 50,000
people and then they have to pay 25
dollars to read a report about their
data it's kind of insulting so so it
should be available so we have a list of
all the publications that we have and we
have you know I mean a lot of consumers
you know like there's a Time magazine
article today about our paper on motion
sickness so people can read about that
and they know if they've taken that so
tell me about that cuz that's like my
kryptonite I actually have like horrible
motion sickness I mean part of what you
can see is you can look online now you
can fix it your raw data and then we can
fix it but like maybe we can like that
can lead to some kind of target
identification so you find out like this
group of people have it and then I'm
like if you have for instance you have
small children they don't speak you're
driving down to thanksor are they gonna
vomit or not because you'd probably prep
your car 82% yeah whatever percentage
you just described my entire childhood
it's like literally outside the window
cover you in plastic